اوك هذا الفراغ الذي تشكل في الفتره
الماضيه غياب المبادرات الازمات المعماقه
حاله الخلافه الموجوده بين كثير من دول
الاقليم واا استمرار لسنوات طويله بازمات
مفتوحه يدفع بلا شك بارد مثل فرنسا اليوم
الى التفكير
بملئ هذا الفراغ بالبحث على ان تكون جزء
من هذه التركيبه خصوصا ان التنوع اليوم
مطلوب بالنسبه لدوله مثل فرنسا همم وجودها
في افريقيا اليوم هناك منافسه كبرى لابد
من خلق اصوات موازيه عندما نتحدث اليوم عن
بلد مثل الاردن لاستثمار الفرنسيه كبيره
في همم في موضوع المياه في موضوع
الاتصالات يعني فرنسا حاضره بشكل كبير
وبالتالي اليوم تعظيم دورها في على الناس
علاقات سياسيه وعلاقات تصالحيه بين ابناء
هذه المنطقه قد يضمن لها ايضا وجود ويضمن
لها ايضا فرص استثماريه كبرى في حال
تحدثنا مستقبلا كما هو الهدف الموجود
موضوع عن الانفتاح وموضوع التعاون المشترك
والمشاريع الكبرى العادره للحدود اعتقد
نعم هناك فرصه همم يتم العمل عليها الان
بشكل واضح
من هذه القمه نتحدث عن دعوه للعراق
بالابتعاد عن التبعيه الايرانيه هناك ايضا
همم مؤشرات لاعاده او حوار او ربما خطوه
جديده في الحوار بين طهران والرياض العديد
من الرسائل كيف نفهم ذلك هل بفعل هذه
القمه ساهمت في ربما تقريبا جهه النظر همم
هل اخطط خطوه جديده في درب ربما حل حاله
الازمات
اه يا بلا شك قد تكون النقطه الاهم هو
فكره اللقاء المباشر بين المستويين عليين
وزراء خارجيه يعني بهذه الطريقه نكون يعني
قد كسرنا جمود وانطلقنا الى فكره جلوس
الجميع على الطاوله وجلب الخلافات ووضع
هذا الطاوله والحديث مباشره عن هذه
الخلافات انت تعلم ان النقطه الوصول الى
هذه النقطه يعني
بدات منذ زمن لقاءات وصفت بالسريه لقاءات
من الصف الثاني دبلوماسيه موازيه الى ان
نصل الى فكره جمع الاطراف لا نستطيع ان
نقول اننا غدا سنشهد نتائج ايجابيه لمثل
هذه القمم لكن بلا شكوى مجرد اننا ان
نستطيع تكوين اطار لجلوس الجميع على
الطاوله للحديث عن المشاكل هذه المنطقه في
داخل المنطقه بصفتنا كلنا في هذه المنطقه
متضررين من استمرار الصراع والتنافس وحاله
التشهد هذه التي نعيشها منذ سنوات لهذا
اعتقد انه كسر الجنود مهم همم فتح همم
دبلوماسيه
بصوره مباشره بين الطرفين قد تقودنا
مستقبلا او في الفتره القريبه الى همم
لقاءات اكثر جديه ذات طابع اصلاحي بمعنى
اننا نريد ان نصلح هذه العلاقه لاننا
اليوم نعظم المكاسب الاقتصاديه ايضا لجميع
الاطراف كتله بناء اساسها العراق اليوم في
المنطقه مشاريع كبرى اعتقد ان الجميع يجب
ان ينظر اليها من زاويه المستفيد ان هو
البحث عن حلول سياسيه لتعظيم المكاسب
الاقتصاديه من ضمن القضايا التي كانت
مطروح في هذه القمه وملف اللاجئين
السوريين في المنطقه ولا احنا يعني غياب
واضح لسوريا ولبنان في هذه القمه هل قدم
الجديد في هذا الملف
لا لا استطيع ان اقول ان هناك تقديم لجديد
لانه كما تفضل في غياب سوريا ايضا سيكون
دائما معضله في تائه في ايجاد في طريقه
ايجاد حل حقيقي مقبول للجميع لبنان كانت
حاضره كموضوع لكن واضح ان النقطه الارتكاز
الرئيسيه والجديد في هذا الموضوع والتعامل
مع العراق لحكومه الجديده الحفاظ على
الموروث الذي تم بناؤه بين الدول العربيه
والعراق في عهد الكاظمي والبحث ايضا عن
فكره اعاده رسم لنفود الايراني في هذه
المنطقه لاننا نتحدث عن توقيت ايضا وهو
توقيت مهم ازمه معمر في ايران همم الوضع
في سوريا مستمر على ما هو عليه الوضع في
لبنان وبالتالي يعني اليوم ايران مضطره ان
تقدم ايضا نوع من انواع المرونه
الدبلوماسيه الهروب من ازماتها والبحث عن
تفاهمات في هذا الاقليم لهذا اعتقد انه
الموضوع اللاجئين قد لا يكون هو الاساس في
هذه المرحله
الاردن تحديدا
السوريين تحديدا هو بلا شك لكن دعينا نتفق
انه في النهايه اي طرح على هذا المستوى
ولهذه المواضيع دون حضور واشنطن و دون
اقرار من الاداره الامريكيه اعتقد انه
سيبقى دائما مشروع يعني منقوص لهذا مواضيع
متعلقه في سوريا في ظل وجود عقوبات وعدم
تغير في الموقف الامريكي اعتقد اننا لن
نستطيع ان نجذب ان هناك تزحزح في هذه
العلاقه ما يجري اليوم قديما لانه يبني
رؤيه عربيه مشتركه اليوم تتوسع لتصبح رؤيا
اقليميه ايضا لجميع دول ان تحاول ان تصيغ
رؤيه واحده متشابهه تجد فيها مصلحه
وبالتالي تتحول الى كتله ضاغطه ايضا على
المستوى الدولي هذا ممكن ان ان يخفف
الصعاب السابقه في موضوع اعاده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه الحديث عن حال سياسي
مقبول لانك اليوم تطرح مشاريع كبرى في
المنطقه طاقه متصله المنطقه بكامله اذا
بدون حلول سياسيه لا نستطيع ان نمضي قدمها
لكن هذه قد يكون لبن الاولى في بناء طويل
من القضايا الاخرى التي ربما كانت من
المنتظر ان تطرح بشكل غير مباشر في هذا
الاجتماع هو احياء الاتفاق النووي
الايراني بشكل غير مباشر يعني هل تم احراز
اي تقدم هذا المضمار خاصه وان هناك مطالب
يعني هناك طلب من الاتحاد الاوروبي لايران
تحديدا لانهاء الدعم العسكري لروسيا ووقف
قمع التظاهرات هل يمكن الحديث عن ربابه
بدايه اتفاق في هذا الصدر
لكن هو قد يكون بدايه فتح طاقه لايران
للخروج من ازمتها في العلاقه ايضا مع
اوروبا نحن نعلم ان اوروبا بصفاتها الراعي
الشرعي لفكره الاتفاق خمسه زائد واحد هي
التي كانت تضغط بشكل كبير تضررت ايضا
اوروبا من موضوع انقلاب ترامب على هذا
الاتفاق لكن ايران خسرت كثيرا
بديبلوماسيتها المتشدده همم في السنوات
الاخيره وبالتصعيد الذي قامت به باعتبار
ان التيار السكوري كان يؤمن ان التصعيد هو
سيجلب المكاسب السياسيه ويجعل الجميع يرفع
هذا خس ايران كثيرا في العلاقه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي بعد ظهور دورها في اوكرانيا بعد
الحالات القمع المستمر في الداخل الايراني
لهذا هذه قد تكون طاقه صغيره بالنسبه
للايرانيين لفرصه للانتقاء اولا
بالمسؤولين على الملف النووي في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ليه فكره ان ان تعود ايران
للحديث بهذه الجزئيه لكن دعينا لا نغفر
ايضا ان دول الاقليم موجوده في هذا اذا هي
ليست ايران اليوم فقط اوروبا نستطيع ان
ننظر من زاويه اخرى ان دول الاقليم يعني
تقول ايضا انني اريد ان اكون جزء مطلع على
الاتفاق انه وهو ما كانت ترغب به دول
الخليج مثلا منذ البدايه ان تكون مطلع على
الاتفاق وان لا يتم اتفاق فقط مع ايران
على النووي بل بتحديد سياساتها في المنطقه
وقدرتها البلاستيكيه في هذا اعتقد خطوه
على الاقل تفتح طاقه صغيره الايرانيين في
ظل الازمه الموجوده ازمه الثقه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي في محاوله العوده لكن لا نستطيع
ان نقول ان ايران تستطيع فعلا ان تعيد
الامور كما كانت على الاقل في 2015 عاش
بهذه السهوله شكرا جزيلا لك يا سيد عامر
همم اسبال الخبز الاستراتيجي والمحل
الاساسي كنت معنا من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك